Лише на вихідних Ченгіз Акбаба може забирати дворічного сина додому.
Решту часу маленький Міраз мешкає у в'язниці - разом із мамою.
Малюк уже звик, що тато забирає лише його - мама мусить залишатися за тюремними мурами.
Акбаби - курди. Мама Міраза підтримувала близьку до курдів опозиційну партію.
Цього вистачило, аби на чотири роки потрапити за ґрати.
Ми можемо лише радіти, що в'язниця розташована не так далеко,
і ми можемо час від часу забирати дітей.
Акбаба об'єднався разом з іншими татами - чоловіками, чиї дружини - політичні бранки.
Мою дружину засудили за кілька коментарів у соцмережах - більше нічого.
І через це її звинуватили у пропаганді?
Так, у терористичній пропаганді.
Наш адвокат каже, що за такі висловлювання за нормальних умов не карають.
Але ж вони змінили закон.
Через ці антитерористичні закони Міраз та його мама Гюлістан мусять ділити нари.
В камері, де ще півтора десятка інших бранок.
Замість грального майданчика у Міраза - лише бетоноване тюремне подвір'я.
Тому найперше, що хочеться Міразу, коли його забирає батько, -
це побавитися на дитячому майданчику.
Хоча б кілька годин - нормальне дитинство.
Міраз мусить ще два роки жити з мамою у в'язниці.
Він не повинен думати, що його мама залишила його.
Він же ще не розуміє, що її ув'язнили.
Ми можемо лише сподіватися, що це не завдасть йому психологічної травми.
Але це було б дивом, кажуть йому батьки, які вже пройшли через жахіття в'язниці.
10-річний Ренас разом з мамою провів три роки за ґратами.
Але говорити про час, проведений у тюрмі, він не може.
Ми ще досі залишаємо вночі світло в коридорі, бо йому страшно.
Також він здригається від різких звуків.
А коли він іде до туалету, я мушу чекати перед дверима.
Нині у турецьких в'язницях перебувають 700 маленьких дітей зі своїми мамами.
Це підрахунки нечисленних неурядових організацій, які намагаються допомагати таким сім'ям.
Вони нарікають, що для держави таких дітей - наче не існує.
Тюремний персонал взагалі не кваліфікований, аби реагувати на потреби малюків.
А уряд не може навіть відповісти, в яких в'язницях і скільки дітей перебуває.
Турецькі в'язниці вже давно переповнені.
Понад 160 тисяч людей за останні два роки потрапили за ґрати з політичних причин.
Уряд запланував будівництво ще 230 нових тюрем.
Прихильники турецького президента Ердогана підтримують це.
Вони кажуть, що матері у в'язницях лише прикидаються жертвами.
Слід перевірити, чи ці жінки свідомо спершу завагітніли, а вже потім вчинили протиправні дії,
щоб згодом використати таку ситуацію з пропагандистською метою проти уряду.
Увечері Міраз з татом відвідує своїх курдських бабусю і дідуся.
Ті певна річ, дуже радіють нагоді його побачити.
Те, що нині в Туреччині так багато політв'язнів відбувають термін разом зі своїми дітьми,
не випадковість для сучасної Туреччини.
Жінку, яку засудити за крадіжку, можуть звільнити вже через два роки, якщо в неї є маленька дитина.
Але для наших дружин такої можливості немає.
Вихідні добігають кінця. Сьогодні Міраз має знову повернутися до тюрми - до мами.
Тато щоразу непокоїться - що його сина цього разу чекає за ґратами?
З ким його дружина та дитина мусять ділити камеру?
Вони дуже залежать від толерантності співкамерниць.
Якщо Міраз плакатиме вночі, вони можуть поскаржитись.
15 жінок сплять в одній камері. Це не дає мені спокою.
Але Міраз не повинен помітити занепокоєння батька.
Прощання перед в'язницею.
Ходімо, ми йдемо до мами.
За ворітьми в'язниці батько мусить віддати сина чужим людям.